find anybody wants to be a Basquiat no
YouTube okay I also like how I have
errors and purples oh my god taking 20
hours download the map but it works for
me Oh fine hahahahaha oh my god I can't
do anything rash keep going with this
good I'm not even playing right now I'm
spectating Oh what it looks like for me
oh my god oh my god cabinets are errors
the gas station is an error
hey a mine error don't shoot me don't
shoot me I'm right next to you jack now
your pot oh cool oh wow I get accused
big waited timing was too good oh my god
there's gonna be so hard to watch
do you guys like the entire inside of
the building and all pink yeah no no
yeah it's fine actually is totally fine
though I have literally no errors oh
come downstairs are you a pro yeah
purple everything is purple
everything yeah should we try to get a
new aim then yeah yeah I can do that I
mean hmm that'll work we're starting
what can we take keen is everybody in
we're up yeah I gave up because you guys
told me to stop Jack restarted the thing
Oh
Maps only oh well I'll do that then oh
my god we all agree to agree to do
anything all right
there is a hunter all right hunters win
hahahahaha all right I mean we end up
the same teams as last time I know this
map is awful I'm with my god maybe this
is a five star map yeah but it was
brand-new so maybe you'll know there's
an invisible wolves oh it's not
invisible if you do that oh Christ
hang on but I need like just thirty five
more seconds hang on are you I got I got
13 show that's what I'm saying that I'm
fine this is fine everything's fine
every day is a
bring it I can't see [ __ ] the map again
small here we go
welcome to pawpaws everybody [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] I feel like I play Hawk gmod guess
who on this map I feel like I should see
you guys already buy your expletive oh
hi [ __ ] no no I man Oh thought that was
me where do you see yourself wait does
never like to have any fun whatsoever if
I play Tetris he would just stack the
blocks neatly and finish the level like
a [ __ ] dick Bobby you're dead you
don't get to talk anymore oh hey Jackie
by hanging out the window for you know
you're just on the grog corner how am i
god you're wizard
yeah do it look am I going to find you
every house gute toward the middle of
the oh that's good oh I'm not moving
stop you're a wizard you're straight-up
wizard okay well yeah you're good yeah
okay good is there only two houses that
are actually searchable aside yeah the
fact that the rest of the room looks a
little bit like an apocalypse okay
Jackie go ahead no no god damn it Bobby
V you sold me you get really ratted me
out geez never they'll never find you I
don't know went out the window in the
wrong house
hahaha you're in the wrong house yeah
wrong house loser why don't you go
across the street nerd better really
don't however that herself I think you
got the wrong number bruh wait I think
you're in the right place check yeah
maybe you need to comment on one to get
yourself out of this sticky situation
nothing looks wrong here yeah Nick he's
a clue he's goo what what I see him in
before or even under I've been told you
saw her in the bed mm-hmm see well the
roof is you gotta fiddler on the roof
there's actually the concurrent sequel
of the seaman of the fiddler on the roof
and it's written from the perspective of
his unbelievably also known as the
Ziggler on the roof even in Mexico
Fiddler on the Roof
or semen on the roof forgive the room
with the lamp on the altar lamps on the
flower and the campy revamp of it seamen
around not as serious some founded
offensive but honestly some good songs
he done and and v sir movie the female
boy was also a classic that was regarded
by the horrible jokes until they decide
to kill baby I got into the house and
not not be sitting down okay are you
guys are in the completely wrong house
like you were just no we're not you are
in the other I said yeah oh yeah you're
doing the wrongness what's that extra
systems I know I was gone for the
pianist the pianist the scene I didn't
come across I've sort of been the
heart-wrenching the heart-wrenching
movie that featured a great performance
by that actor I don't know Seamans list
yeah yeah demon meeting keep it seemed a
nice it in seaman's list list even
harder that would be famous less three
sorry I'm harder compass if you on the
nose if that's a little much okay that's
entitled love you figure this is a
client I'm shooting in the key state a
minute with a look at that whoa who's
here happening
who's smashing are you in the sale
before you and the other one I'm in the
other house I'm in a haunted house this
is he breaking it ran oh yeah when you
want passion it just like falls over and
break so you saw that did you
what on the world breaking everything
yeah [ __ ] for that we did I know
shade yeah and I think God breaking my
brothers and sisters how you get it oh
wait yeah are you talking about wait was
that closing was I'm gonna know you
maybe you maybe you're close
maybe I was close maybe you are maybe
I'm a liar if you're a dead man oh I
really just want to find the basement
please keep hitting that
all right wait on their number I've got
your number one focus is who you are I'm
not hating what are you doing oh no I
don't see no explosions everywhere it's
really not right on this map to look at
that and you think where you going no
that's a laundry room I don't see you
anymore
all right wait okay I think waves in
this house oh hello
whoa Jesus yeah you just want place [ __ ]
in it smashing all right Bob we got to
start making calls here oh hi yeah all
you got to do is wait mark look at this
flag over here at this house Oh a second
oh yeah I got I got away yeah we're
second it's okay wait no mark come look
at our from this angle please yeah like
it's like it's waving in the air but
it's stuck
it feels weird sue I [ __ ] up from the
Sun hey Jack that is absurd I know all
right I feel a little bad absurd wait
hang on is it absurd up it's a little
absurd it's almost as ridiculous as
someone being a giant red cooler running
around going with Mark and they play
with Mark for me no I was toying with
mark and then you came outside and shot
me um he might be a pair of glasses baby
[Music]
that means I'm right no no I see him
he's out here I [ __ ] shot your
brother earlier don't shoot my [ __ ]
bro you coming in he's a little he's a
little coaster on the granite so I saw
my crane yeah I shot the thing that you
became he's a very high coaster I help
you Bob I help you don't have nasty
little [ __ ] discs well I was originally
an accordion in that room you went into
oh really yeah I Bob where are you going
um I can't see where the fence is and is
not so really I'm not going over there
that's oh thanks they're mine all right
listen closely wait
they'll give away what they are I'm
going bold I'm
own bold mark okay he's a font good call
got me he can air something he's called
a fan I'm definitely an heiress I don't
want to don't listen to the extreme
noise that's very obviously coming from
this house is none of your concern
this is fine
don't come in I don't need your help
don't come in my room mom please please
please go away
I find a basement do you really want to
go find there everything else is cool
there you got 300 and degrees right one
picture of a valley dude is a barn here
we should just get drinks yeah I realize
copyrighted I'm gonna keep looking at it
I get marked an angle alive yeah I'm so
alive I'm in a good Heidi along I think
you were smashing that one over my head
it made it to your problem oh you want
you want jet copic beer I want that all
well you grab the boat yeah that's fine
I know what that is
we have pep we have idea of top shelter
as a top shelf over there
we have littie cola some non copyrighted
sodas yeah I'm kind of hammered hours of
just you close the door it is behind me
I was pretty interested to see how the
spot was gonna work out but I guess no
one's gonna come play with me no it's
fine don't worry about it dude someone
will like you eventually I'm just coming
nothing looks off in here
just come on in a seat why just come sit
down don't you come have a seat
yeah what to have a seat why don't you
have a seat why don't you have a seat
what does it mean you are you also a
city living Marc
oh you're reacting to him I tell you
were reacting to me I don't know who
that was but nothing someone's out in
the street and someone's in the wrong
house hmm I think that means I'm in the
wrong house well if there's only one of
you is in a ha whoa whoa today gross no
no an ID slipped I just look so like I I
just made
get behind you and then around the back
of the shed [ __ ] yeah way mean no wait
wait direction hey hey Mark come towards
me I went for track you all right where
are you I don't know I sure you know
where I am
okay all right I'm coming to you I'm
gone what's this I don't know I do see
your life holy [ __ ] Bob hello friend
oh you would not believe the adventure I
had bah ha ha ha
oh the bench I know he's advancing on
the line here in Sweden hey the other
benches were all near trees ok I was
just playing my character yeah don't be
judgy about this it was [ __ ]
ridiculous cuz like I just managed to
slip out the door of Jack and then like
wavy towards me I don't know how I got
away I don't know how the way I rock hey
ah don't want it she's always in a shed
way ok
I got you covered come on man how did it
why is that all right we'll give you
know I got nothing why no no no it's
late girl what do I open yeah what if we
have God hang on Wow yeah here we go we
open this other door and help you oh
wait I'm trying to follow a few in push
it will push you in oh boy ok I can't
become anything else what do we give you
know what would give you some we're
working on it we're watching you in
there it's fine this is fine I'm
pressing stuff well there you go there
you go you popped in alright we're going
to look away we're going to close the
door okay what are you
I really good in here you gotta live it
up cool
are you ever going away okay hello you
look again you can look again you can
look at it alright I'm are three two one
you know what I don't think he needs any
help
yeah we should just leave and you know
we'll come back and check on you in a
bit okay buddy you're back yeah you just
cook for a bit you cook guys yeah I can
pick up [ __ ] but I won't let me be
comment banging look at how AM Chris oh
no way so so where's the basement I'm
interested in that when you going to a a
house it's on the whole it's one of the
doors in the hole it's just like
camouflage against the wall with a brown
door every step 5 I'm a goddamn giant
destroying the universe hey Bob I saw
something lady didn't lose Bobby oh come
on via the magical changing shadow Kevin
oh look at my shame hanging in here
trying to okay you check behind that
tree in the corner
no no not this tree oh yeah good what
what if I scream I want a go this way
nothing around the tree what if I Olli
look this way oh no there's nothing
audition oh I'm not shooting in you know
I just a tree shooting around you have
you ever heard of Kinetico motor oil
it's the best
Oh
Oh there you go that was just
embarrassment yeah that was bad away
look in the ground all right I know what
what we'll do is I'm gonna ride you to
victory Jack let's do this yeah all
right okay okay
I'm not moving is this working no push
you can't pick up anything I can't move
I'm inside you huh all right there okay
all right
you'd be the one making that a zombie
I'm early okay kill me oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] game messin with my life my fun
my life my fun my world my game I only
care about em II my enjoyment it's all
Sean's mod for a reason guys yeah yeah
okay I'll [ __ ] sake I hear a cleany
clang now if I hang everything's fine I
didn't have to do
everything's fine don't worry about it
is it yes everybody home oh sorry I
panic oh my god Bobby you here hey Mark
I'm sucked good are you either way now
where are Jack yeah no I'm not in there
are you the one in the bar with me yeah
I'm not scary this side but even I work
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna panic I'm
gonna take it like a man about to stick
my ass up against this radiator good too
late oh hey I did it
I just randomly shut the chairs yeah
like a rocket rolling behind the house
is fine precisely money sorry last round
I did the same thing that's how I knew
my question yeah okay be smart
that's not smart be six hit okay
same joke without that from battleship
the gamer battleship the movie I'll shut
the movie bride yeah [ __ ] me nice
enough in this nice [ __ ] right on
enough of Sydney autumn from Gracie
Belle bro
Oh shucks but I think it's your way
around what's going on over here
nothing I'm stuck but it's fine it's
mine Jack oh nothing very about this
chair looks a little suspicious but into
a movie in the context of food I can
hear myself as I yell right fine fine
fine it's fine it's fine it's right
through the window this is not a [ __ ]
Bob what's happening in there Bobby
might want to Autobot it's fine I'm fine
it's fine trying to find it no it's fine
I gotta Chaldean move Transpo Cassy [ __ ]
where's the exit where's the off-ramp is
not in any of the places you've gone
you're hoping you'd come oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
goddamn it makes my side turn plane Bob
thanks thanks yeah I was nice right I
was cool it's cool yeah
it's that other one yeah it's me whoa
you're going to accuse me Bob yeah it's
almost like that's an accurate thing to
accuse you of wait I think you're pretty
solid wait yeah but I can't actually
move so I mean they're in the same house
but you're pretty solid I'm sure I'm
fine they'll never they wouldn't they're
look here they probably leaves oh hey it
looks here oh I think I'm talking out
loud I am ruined that they can't hear it
with the power of imagination woman's
outside like a macaroon oh yeah here the
stomping in the snow I'm watching Bernie
it's very that it's pretty that plier
yeah yeah I don't understand
I think Wade's a tiny thing underneath
the thing but I'm not not no no I'm not
it'd be pretty easy to find if you're
not stupid yeah yeah well then I must
not have looked in the right room yet
accurate yeah probably
I'm sure you're right once I walked into
the right room it was immediately clear
of you Oh hedemark in the window I'm
here we had great scores
[Music]